pop
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après avoir été reçus à brazzaville par
le président fulbert youlou monsieur
marshall se rend à léopoldville pour
inspecter les casques bleus de l'onu et
rencontrer les membres du cabinet de
monsieur lumumba qui se trouve au même
moment à new york conversations
difficiles qui font rapidement remonter
la tension combo alors que la mise en
place des contingents internationaux
laissait espérer une détente prochaine
les exigences du gouvernement congolais
rome la situation explosive et si la vie
reprend à léopoldville sous l'oeil
débonnaire des soldats de l'onu
la ville n'en est pas moins privées de
toute activité réelle tandis qu'une
armée de chômeurs
murmura ses parts
sa capitale pas pressés aux couleurs
nationales et à celle de la communauté
madagascar célèbre son indépendance le
président de six rames
viens découvrir devant monsieur debré la
gac ans et les représentants de soixante
six nations l'aspect de l'indépendance
et et donner le signal des réjouissances
populaires qui vont jusqu'à la nuit fait
régner à tananarive une extraordinaire
ambiance d'enthousiastes
et le président anti roms devaient
déclarer nous n'oublierons jamais que la
france a été l'inspiratrice de cette
communauté et nous a guidés vers
l'indépendance
et
entretiens secrets franco-allemand au
château de rambouillet le général de
gaulle avait invité le chancelier
adenauer à venir envisagée avec lui une
nouvelle politique européenne destinée à
assurer une coopération et une cohésion
plus étroite et plus efficace entre des
pays dont les destins se trouve
aujourd'hui intimement liés la politique
américaine ce n'est qu'au même moment en
veilleuse en donnant assister à la
convention républicaine de chicago le
président et se nourrir ou vos sa
succession en conseillant à ses amis des
lieux comme candidat à la maison blanche
richard nixon l'actuel vice président
celui ci est investi à l'unanimité et
sera donc aux prochaines élections
présidentielles
l'adversaire des démocrates qui nous lie
et dans l' enthousiasme du congrès
républicain richard nixon désigne
aussitôt envie qu'à votre coach actuel
délégué à l'onu pour être vice
présidence il est lui même élu président
originalité exhibitionnisme ou
conviction la coupe de cheveux à la
mohican est de rigueur chez les néo
dadaïste de tokyo à l'heure de la
création artistique
certains maîtres européens nous avait
déjà accoutumés à ce genre de conception
pictural dont la veuve gagne aujourd'hui
le japon ou du moins une secte originale
qui a en tout cas la modestie de
s'intituler celle des antilles artistes
la secte plus honorable des culturistes
et des athlètes s'emploie de son côté a
décerné ses prix annuels nationaux et
européens une vingtaine de concurrents
se dépensent sans compter sur le podium
de trouver pouces sont déjà chevronné
champion de départements ou des quatre
pays étrangers représentés et ils ne
sont pas moins de 5 à recevoir
finalement la récompense de leurs
efforts et de leur plastique
le plus bel athlète d'europe était lui
et avec lui le plus beau france le
champion d'europe le champion de france
et enfin pour mettre tout le monde
d'accord à champion international l'onu
de vue cependant quelques ça
[Musique]
sommes-nous revenus au début du siècle
dans ses allées l'apparition du lacroix
de la ville jolie nos du tonneau trois
roues châssis bois qui fit l'admiration
des foules élégante en 1898 ceux de la
6è raynaud d'un voiture de course qui
enleva de haute lutte la coupe des
voiturettes en 1907 et seul d'un
énigmatique granby peuvent donner ce
vertige vertige que continue à accentuer
la panhard levassor 2895 moteur la
brûlures et direction que de vaches
convient sans doute au drague et au
grand prix de la belle époque
[Musique]
tout cela n'est pas un songe nous sommes
tout simplement près de lyon au château
de la roche taillée où il ya de s'ouvrir
le musée de l'automobile
cette création qui semble unique dans le
monde rassemble tous ceux qui dans les
70 ans qui précèdent fut le visage de
l'automobile à côté du prototype à
direction centrale de vimy de 1949
le prototype de la deux chevaux de 1936
[Musique]
leno de peugeot et léon bollée s'ils
lisent avec celui de roland pilain avec
hotchkiss avec l'abbé délia de 1913 et
la peugeot de 1896 ancêtre de la 404 et
hand on admirera le coupé docteur de
dion bouton de 1900 et le vis-à-vis
rochet schneider de 1894 on s'attendre
ira devant sa direction ne s'agit que
son radiateur sont pistons ar libre et
sa transmission par chaîne et courroye
c'est l'ancêtre de la collection la
quatre chevaux renou de 1900 ne rappelle
que de très loin celle que nous
connaissons il ya aussi avec ses titres
de noblesse que sont les affiches et les
photos du temps le char à banc de l'as
poulx jase de 1896 et la panhard
levassor double fight en 2008 198
utilisèrent dit on le roi des belges
léopold ii et cléo de mérode et d'autres
temps d'autres dont l'iconographie
automobile garde la silhouette et vante
les mérites selon les rites publicitaire
d'un autre âge
[Musique]
musée de l'automobile mais aussi musée
du cycle la petite reine est l'hôte ici
de sa royale rival et l'on remontera
ainsi le temps à petites étapes à
travers le granby le rotary britannique
tous deux de 1875 et le vélo de michao
de 1869
jusqu'à cette douaisienne qui nous
ramène à napoléon
[Musique]
l'himalaya connaît de nouveau la grande
affluence des alpinistes avant ce riz
lary qui se propose de partir à la
recherche de l'abominable homme des
neiges une expédition japonaise vient de
conquérir l'un des sommets de la chaîne
la plus haute du monde
le himal giuly à 7800 mètres d'altitude
[Musique]
le film de l'expédition tourné par l'un
de ses membres ne donne qu'une faible
idée des difficultés rencontrées dans
l'ascension mais ils montrent qu'en
progressant jusqu'au sommet la cordée
japonaise n'a jamais employé d'appareils
à oxygène et a néanmoins
elle faisait une magnifique premier
à quelques jours des jeux olympiques de
rome un nouvel espoir s'affirme dans les
rangs français avec robert bogeys qui
vient à l'occasion de la rencontre
france angleterre à londres de battre le
record de france du 10000 m courante ici
avec le dossard numéro 1 go j'ai même
son action avec prudence laissant les
anglais elle donne et merriman en blanc
mené successivement le train pour lui
[Musique]
et
sur la fin budget se replace en seconde
position et la attendre les derniers 100
mètres pour fournir son effort avec 29
minutes
une seconde 6e robert roger réussi l'une
des cinq meilleures performances de
l'année sur 10000 mètres et s'adjuge un
record de france que des près de quatre
ans à la mine championnat
là
[Musique]